kartha d dig the lodge author of
Hoover's FBI the inside story of
Hoover's trusted lieutenant why'd you
write the book Brian I felt like I had
to either me or one of 10,000 other X
agents of the FBI our current agents of
the FBI but mostly agents of that
particular hero they've been so many
distortions of history ludicrous yellow
journalism to the fact that people
wanted to make a fast buck out of by
spreading dallisa and arrogant rumors of
rumors were totally false
innuendo which you'll find throughout
the book and which I combat I wanted the
book to be believable to have the
ability so consequently I indicated our
falls from J edgar Hoover's Falls but
the book had to be written so that I
feel that my children my grandchildren
other people's children and
grandchildren can go to the college and
university libraries and find something
besides garbage on the shelves
concerning the FBI Varia and about GI
groover let me jump to the end you have
a chapter in which you tell the story of
mr. Hoover's last day when he died when
was that that was 1972 I believe was
March 2nd 1972 if I'm not mistaken in
his job then his job with director of
the FBI he died in the job how old was
he he was 78 years of age in the job in
the job where were you that day I was in
Indianapolis Indiana presiding over a
meeting and I got a call from dick Klein
Dean's who was Attorney General and he
swore me to secrecy and then indicated
that mr. Hoover had died and I was
shocked I was distressed frankly I that
I he'd been in the job so long and I
thought he was going to stay on there
forever as a matter of fact he told me
once I will never leave this job and he
never did but Klein Dean said the
Attorney General asked me to come back
to Washington and take over the bureau
in an acting capacity until President
Nixon could appoint me or someone else I
told him I had to check with the
chairman of the board of PepsiCo whom I
was reporting to and working for at the
time as a vice president of PepsiCo and
I also wanted to check my wife and to
think a little bit about it
and he said he knew would be a financial
loss compared to my job in private
industry but that he would appreciate it
and so with the president I would come
back and take over I said well give me
at least until 12:00 noon to give you an
answer and he said fine and I called him
back at 12:00 noon and he indicated that
the President Nixon show wanted me but
he also wanted somebody else to but when
I come back just in an interim capacity
I told him no I would not do that and so
that was about it and on that day that
mr. Hoover died he had a visitor who you
say they had trouble knowing what to do
with who was that and why was she there
that was Linda Bird Johnson and I knew
her well she was a good friend when her
father was in the White House but she
was there to interview J Edgar Hoover
about his two dogs Karen Terriers and
frankly the agents didn't know what to
do with her and finally when I did tell
her after the press release had gone out
from the White House that Hoover had
died she was shocked she rushed to the
phone and told her father and he was
shocked also LBJ was still living in at
the LBJ Ranch and in the Texas
she was regarded by Hoover as somewhat
of a foster daughter and as much as she
her mother father and her sister Luke
had someone of a proprietary interest
and her opinion to the interview
occasionally and she was doing this time
I believe her good housekeeping how long
was he director of the FBI from 1919
when he became acting director he became
director in 1924 until 1972 how long did
you work for him almost 29 years almost
a lot make a career out of Brian what
was the highest job you had as his
deputy the formal title was assistant to
the director but he called a deputy and
at times when he was out of town I act I
served as a acting director of the FBI
one of the stories that you deal with is
that data he died that you say an author
made all kinds of suggestions that a you
can tell the story about a body being
removed from the house at a time that he
wasn't even dead yet what was that whole
story about what I had to do with the
allegations made by a number of
individuals again having no basis in
fact whatsoever allegations at the FBI
had secret files hidden away in NJ edgar
Hoover's house he had taken them and
placed them there for safekeeping there
were no secret files in his house or no
files whatsoever in his house concerning
the FBI others felt that his body had
been placed in a blanket at seven
o'clock in the morning and sent to the
funeral home
actually his body had not even been
discovered by that time so again it was
just false allegations concerning secret
suppose secret files and his body had
been taken away in a clandestine matter
which was absolutely false as are many
of the allegations concerning him he had
his faults and I'll be glad to tell you
any of those in my opinion but
nevertheless having secret files at his
home or having secret files anywhere
Brian the allegation has been made time
and time again that he had secret files
for the purpose of blackmailing members
of Congress that's totally preposterous
we had behind Helen Gandhi's desk and
Helen Gandy with his secretary
for over 45 years we had to pile
cabinets and one of the file cabinets
had two and a half drawers of files when
some of those
I was concerned John F Kennedy Eleanor
Roosevelt a concern a Undersecretary of
State who had committed homosexual act
and concerned Richard Nixon and various
other notables now why why did we have
them there simply because of the fact
that we didn't want a young gs2 clergy
coming in from the boondocks and making
a beeline right away for those files to
satisfy their curiosity and then
possibly going out and advising mom or
dad or someone else I haven't had a
chance to look at the file of this great
personality so we would take the top
files of Notables and take them and put
them behind Helen Gandy's desk there
were not secret files I could look at
them any any individual on the top level
in the FBI caligo if they had a
legitimate reason for doing so but they
weren't secret files they were open to
all of us at all times and the only
reason we moved in was to keep prying
eyes and going out and gossiping FDR
asked the bureau to investigate his wife
yes he did he had information and I
don't know from where but he has to who
were that particular time to put a
surveillance on mrs. Roosevelt of the
purpose of determining whether or not
she was having secret rendezvous with
with a certain earning army colonel and
with a state trooper in New York and we
did that accordingly at the instructions
of the president which brings up to mind
the FBI has been used or misused by many
presidents and by attorneys general was
the FBI is under you say that an agent
dressed up as a milkman yes and and what
happened well he asked he went in the
apartment where a mrs. Roosevelt was
staying and she was dressed in a
housecoat at the time and the individual
that the President Roosevelt was
somewhat suspicious I was in the
apartment at the time and as Roosevelt
was baking in breakfast and this was the
only way that the agent could determine
whether or not she was meeting with this
individual and he did get the proof and
he put it in the report and the report
was given to the president gerrae gain a
sense of what the president dividend
none whatsoever and we could care less
frankly it was miss usage of the FBI by
a president and I think here again that
then President Roosevelt misuse the FBI
more than any other president although
they have been used by most all
presidents since the beginning or since
the inception of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation did you say you caught a
Secretary of State and a homosexual I
know an Under Secretary of State under
secretaries yes did you name we didn't
catching the report was given that the
Under Secretary of State's traveling to
Senator Keller's funeral in Tennessee
had lured a porter into a bunk bed
during that particular trip and we were
asked by the President to investigate
that matter and we did and report here
again was turned over to President
Roosevelt but the copy was kept in FBI
files how did you decide what
information to put in this book and did
you I mean is there any restriction on
this kind of information and how much of
it is first-time servant I don't think
there should be any restriction on the
information I put the inside information
concerning the president's asking us to
do various things and there simply
because of the fact to prove there were
no secret files that was a basis for
doing it in that particular chapter
whether the restrictions currently today
or not I don't know but when I left the
FBI I took with me
only the matters that were pertaining to
me personally as a matter of information
but also I requested the director of the
FBI who was judge Webster at that
particular time the send me copies of
every memorandum I wrote between 1951
and 1970 particularly had anything to do
with the White House by the Congress and
I received over 6,000 memoranda from the
FBI under the Freedom of Information Act
that was the basis of considerable by
information and the rest came from
personal memories that I recall very
vividly could others have asked for that
same information that the the memos that
you wrote or is it just you that could
ask for that absolutely they could
receive the same thing as I receded they
only ask for and under the Freedom of
Information I was given no favors in
that regard
what did you think of J Edgar Hoover he
was a very complex man he was very
formal austere aloof he was a
perfectionist he was probably the best
public relations toe dancer in
Washington and so far as realizing the
importance of something and taking
advantage of it but by the same token I
think that he could very safely and very
properly be called the father of modern
day law enforcement why because he
himself advocated and promoted the
centralization of fingerprinting by
usage of police all throughout the world
the free world that is he brought into
new standards raising the standards
rather of law enforcement and giving law
enforcement officers something to be
proud of in handling their position the
National Crime Information Center which
is a great boon and a new initiative for
law enforcement has saved many lives
that is the recording of stolen goods in
stolen automobiles and stolen jewelry
and paintings and the listing of
fugitives throughout the United States
and many other things the FBI laboratory
the training of police he brought all
this about it may not have been his idea
to start out with but nevertheless he
capitalize on it and brought it about
for usage for all of law enforcement and
it has helped law enforcement
considerably whose Clyde Tolson I told
was the associate director of the FBI
for many of the latter years of Hoover's
life Clyde Tolson was sick he had a
stroke he had several other things that
happened to him and he was ill quite a
bit at the time but in his heyday he was
a very sharp individual had a brilliant
mind good handle administrative work or
paper work faster than anyone I've ever
seen
where is he in this picture Clyde Tolson
is on the top picture he is right here
about him he's standing him down to the
bottom he's sitting in the far end of
the table and that is the living
quarters of the president County of says
let there be Thompson and you're off to
the right next to him
that's correct and London Johnson has
his back to London Johnson had his back
to us how close was Clyde Tolson to J
Edgar Hoover
he was an ally let me preface my remarks
this way Brian please every man needs a
close friend somebody he can trust
somebody's loyal to him what is his wife
his son his daughter goober had no
family after his mother died so he
needed a friend an ally and Clyde Tolson
was that a lie someone he could trust
now the basic wrong in that was Clyde
Tolson showed slavich disobedience to
jr. grew a slavish obedience to
geography when he should at times
disagreed with him for the good of the
organization but if the boss meaning mr.
Hoover said something Clyde Tolson said
this is what we've got to do I can
remember many times when the executive
conference voted 11 to 0 unanimously for
a specific matter but it was sent in to
Hoover and Hoover would say no I
disagree
Oh Tolson would call us back together
and said obviously we were wrong Hoover
would remember the director was right
and therefore we got to do it over again
there was lavash obedience there there
was loyalty to the Corps and I think at
times that Tolson and any of us maybe we
would have lost our jobs we would've
lost the battle to win a skirmish but I
think Tolson should have showed the
disagreement at times who is said
Richardson and Clint Murchison there
were friends of Hoover they were
multi-millionaires of Texas they owned
the New York Central Railroad for a time
they are many other things particularly
land in Texas they would go on vacations
and Hoover would meet them at the del
Charo Hotel in San Diego he would also
meet him in other places they paid his
bills from time to time they paid his
dinner bills they paid his hotel bills
from time to time he thought that he was
uncorruptible and in particularly his
later years it was wrong for him to
allow this to be done but he knew in his
own mind that they were never asking for
any favors and they never did they did
not kind of capitalize on the fact that
they had paid his bills then it wasn't
considered totally wrong
today in the daylight yes it is
but as director of the FBI that should
not have been done you have a whole
chapter in here devoted to the gay
director question mark why simply
because the fact I wanted to combat the
distortions of history the ludicrous
charges that have been raised about the
fact that Edgar Hoover was a homosexual
and a transvestite I live with a man as
far as being in having office next door
or next two years for 15 years I
traveled with him I've stayed in the
same suite with him on occasion I was in
his home he was in my home on very
infrequent occasions I knew the man I
knew he was not a homosexual
as did all of his people who work for
him I knew that he was not a
transvestite he was a deeply religious
aloof formal individual who was greatly
charged by the bias rearing by his
mother who was a very formal a deeply
religious person and well disciplined
let me read you a statement you made on
your book in that chapter he was
certainly more of a man than mr. Somers
and I've seen both at close quarters yes
are you talking about
Tony summers interviewed me for his book
and he did not use use hardly any of the
proofs that I gave him or faxed I gave
him concerning the fact that that the
junior Hoover's activities or the FBI's
activities and I think that you know
having known mr. Hoover and being in his
office almost every day particularly
during the last 15 years I was there
that I knew him very well and I thought
that I cinched in summers what exactly
what his makeup was and I think that who
was much more of a man than summers what
would have been wrong if he had been a
homosexual in the light of the society
and they did the the Society of that
particular day back in the 60s and 70s
here was a man of a director of the FBI
who was charged with some of the gravest
security and espionage problems of the
nation he would be totally subject to
blackmail and many other things if he
had been a homosexual or a transvestite
but let me add to that
and what had worth the proof that he was
a homosexual
summers and others have indicated that
there were pictures involved where are
the pictures who are the sources one of
his main sources was an individual a
woman in New York who was a convicted
perjurer an inmate of Rikers Island
prison and who felt that her husband had
gained inside information from J Edgar
Hoover to gain a divorce from her in a
messy suit Hoover had not given
rosensteil any information or anyone
else but that was one of summer's main
sources other sources that he used some
um were corpses and I think if the
corpses were dug up today they'd be
astonished to find had been quoted in
this particular way but nevertheless
there's no proof whatsoever that the man
was a homosexual or transvestite what
could have been wrong with it only the
fact that he would have been subject to
blackmail have been stigmatized
accordingly as director of the FBI did
you know Abe Fortas yes I knew and well
he was a good friend
I admired in the respect team when he
was an attorney when he was Lyndon
Johnson's attorney and when he was on
the Supreme Court I thought he had a
very keen mind he tells stories though
about him in which he say he was where
it isn't here downright unethical and he
was on the Supreme Court what were you
talking about
I don't say that he was unethical I said
that maybe he may have stretched the
line a little bit in still remaining
LBJ's attorney even though he was a
justice to the Supreme Court but my
association with him came about in
several different ways number one the
fact that I felt that we felt who were
and I both felt and Tolson that that
Bobby Kennedy was attempting to give the
supreme court possibly some false
information in its in his punches and so
far as usage of wiretaps and microphones
our concern also became the time and
Lyndon Johnson wanted his prospective
son-in-law Chuck Robb who's an hour
senator investigated prior to the time
that he married Linda Berg and he asked
to both Justice Fortas and me to handle
that brief investigation we did there
was nothing
wrong with Chuck Robb nothing derogatory
his background he had been a
distinguished captain in the Marine
Corps but that was miss usage of the FBI
but that was again was dealing with a
Portis when he was a justice what I was
referring to earlier about I had to go
this is these are your words of course
Portis his involvement in the matter was
blatantly unethical and this is that
whole matter of Bobby Kennedy and the
bugs and and that you ended up going up
to the Supreme Court when he was on the
court and meeting with him would you
tell us more about that yes I felt that
this was in the black case the usage of
electronic surveillance of microphones
in the black case and who were felt at
the time that the Department of Justice
actually Thurgood Marshall who later
became a justice went up and argued the
keys for the Justice Department
concerning black black it indicated that
the usage his attorneys had indicated
the users of microphones would negate
any decision made in his case and
Thurgood Marshall argued against that
and we were afraid that not only would
be would be be stigmatized if the
Department of Justice did not give out
the correct facts which we didn't think
they would do because they wanted to
escape being both politicians they want
to escape any blame or stigmatization
themselves but we felt the court with
meaning will lean over backward to knock
out all electronic surveillance which we
desperately needed this is a lobbyist
named Fred black that's exactly in what
year do you remember I don't be in the
middle 60s somewhere I think that's
correct
other good Marshall was Solicitor
General that's correct for signature 364
I believe one of those years but you
ended up going up and having a private
meeting when there was a case before the
court now you say in this in this
chapter that mr. Fortas justice Fortas
had recused himself he does not not
involved in this case that's correct but
he still did something in the he had an
impact on he thought he had the right to
give the other justices a correct facts
it was given to him and I felt he had
the right to do so but would you want
people running in and out of that
Supreme Court talking to the
justices in these cases all the time
like that if they needed the correct
facts yes if we felt that they would not
get the correct facts that the fact
would be bent for politicians to escape
blame on any particular cause they
should have the right to the correct
facts but in a wet briefs are for I mean
the private meetings that are supposed
to be not allowed that's very true
that's very true but by the same token
we were dealing with facts and I gave
the correct facts to justice for us and
he acted accordingly what happened in
the end then in this case I don't recall
the the outcome of the decision to tell
you did you get what you want to do yes
yes the Supreme Court did not indicate
that the investigative agency the
government should do without electronic
surveillance we say that particular
matter for further usage when necessary
and when approved by the Attorney
General and insofar as the outcome of
the black case is concerned I don't I
don't recall you write about an agent
hasti in the assassination of John F
Kennedy who was he and what role did he
play agent hasti was a special agent
assigned to the Dallas office of the FBI
when Lee Harvey Oswald became involved
with a fair play for Cuba committee in
giving out leaflets on the streets of
New Orleans got in a fistfight with a
bystander on the street because he was
favoring Fidel Castro then later moved
to Dallas agent Ahoskie was assigned the
case involving Lee Harvey Oswald but
more so his Wyatt was a was a not a
naturalized citizen he had come here
from the Soviet Union and he also in
accordance with our policy at that
particular time we were to interview
citizens who came in here people who
came in here from the Soviet Union if
they had not become citizen so I had no
indication of becoming citizens or
showed no indication so as a result he
tried to get in touch with Marina Oswald
on several different occasions agent
hasty
was not present the day that Lee Harvey
Oswald brought a note to the Dallas
office of the FBI the note in our
opinion was not threatening but the note
was given to agent hostage later on he
showed that the special agent charge
whose name was Gordon Shanklin Shanklin
indicated that the note should be
destroyed hostage states that he
followed the si si s he especially
didn't charges instructions but he too
agreed that the note was odd threatening
and he did destroy it in retrospect he
now states that they didn't think that
that was a good idea that he should have
saved it but he did say it was under his
agent in charges instructions that had
nothing to do with the indication that
the president John F Kennedy was
assassinated by Lee Harvey Oswald Lee
Harvey Oswald even though he had been
sympathetic to the fair play for Cuba
committee had been to Mexico had been
the Soviet Union was not considered a
threat to the president United States
but was not considered a threat to
anyone
he was a milquetoast to a great extent a
loner he'd been in the Marine Corps he
was a marksman in the Marine Corps yes
he'd been kicked out he went to the
Soviet Union where he met marina married
her it came back to the States
but he was despite all that he was not
considered a threat to anyone and under
our policies that particular time we did
not furnish the information concerning
Lee Harvey Oswald to the Secret Service
we did many other individuals from the
Dallas area at that bit of time that
President Kennedy was going there but
Oswald was the agent assigned to that
particular matter and Oswald I think
while he should have brought the note to
the attention of the FBI but FBI
headquarters nevertheless did not do so
with the instructions of his agent in
charge as a result he was later
disciplined as were other FBI personnel
in the matter he opened the book but
with a chapter called Hoover's FBI and
this sentence Messrs Jenkins
Walter Jenkins Moyer's bill moyers of
PBS and carted I don't know the name
Carter hood Carter lose re he was an
aide to the president that President
Johnson were particularly interested in
suppressing dissent from black groups
bill moyers interested in suppressing
dissent from black groups the bill
moyers are then is not the bill moyers
of today bill moyers had a assignment
from President Johnson to control what
went on at the Democratic National
Convention in 1964 and the Rules
Committee of the Democrats at that
particular time we're especially
concerned concerning our or regarding
the Mississippi freedom Democratic Party
they wanted to be seated as delegates
Rules Committee voted that the regular
delegates who had been voted on in the
state were to be seated rather than the
Mississippi freedom Democratic Party the
freedom Democratic Party came in and sat
in the seats of the regular delegates
Moyers wanted them out of there more has
wanted to control the situation lawyers
asked us on his radio and had asked his
transmitter ask us to move would be the
FBI to move these delegates out of there
we refused to do so because I thought
that was sheer politics and I refused
anything to do with it but it was a
different situation then and he was
acting under the orders of the president
what was different about then and now
more years is not acting under the
instructions of lyndon b johnson today
four years acting and totally in a
different capacity without instructions
of that particular nature he say you
like president johnson i did what did
you see up close that you liked and what
did you see up close that you didn't
like he was compassionate he would send
the soldiers at Christmastime he wasn't
Oya to my children when my daughter had
the surgery at a hospital in alexandria
he sent her flowers he did many
compassionate things and so far as my
family is concerned as a matter of fact
Brian he one occasion the Easter
one year at Easter time asked my family
in need to go to Camp David and stay
there the entire weekend and we did on
other occasions he was bombastic he was
they had a hot temper I mean he would
humiliate you if you thought that you
done something wrong or something not to
his liking so but I liked it I liked him
as a man then I liked him now I did not
agree with his policies insofar as
legislation involving finances concern
our new programs but that was not up to
me to decide I was simply a liaison
officer between the FBI and President
Johnson why did you call or why did the
FBI agents call the Attorney General
United States Ramsey Clark bull
butterfly
it wasn't the agency was a jailer Hoover
he disliked dealing with Ramsey Clark he
would have been good friends with Tom
Clark but he felt that Ramsey was
somewhat of a pipsqueak and and Tom
Clark son he felt that politics had put
him in his office when he didn't deserve
to be Attorney General and he felt that
the best name he could find for him was
a bull butterfly and he constantly in
conversation with me and other your
executives referred to him as a bull
butterfly yeah I read you back some of
the words you used to describe J Edgar
Hoover and asked you to explain what you
meant by them fain fain fain vain here's
Amanda had an ego he was vain and
personality to some extent he loved
luxuries he would dress in sartorial
splendor to a great extent even though
his surroundings his office and his home
was not didn't express so splendor in
the lease was very common but he himself
personally wanted to be was very vain
and wanting to dress the best he could
and an insisting that the agent Celso
have a proper dress code he was vain and
so far as weight is concerned I recall
one situation where he was addressing to
go to a state dinner at the White House
and he found out that his trousers
wouldn't fit him that they were about
his waist had extended
a couple of inches and so he had to buy
new trousers right away to go to that
state dinner but the following day he
put in to order that all agents should
adhere to the Metropolitan Life
Insurance standards concerning weight
many agents particularly pro football
players a college football players had
you know gained a little weight since
entering the FBI and they had a tough
time getting it off but the weight
control program saved many lives and I
think it was a good thing regardless
three of us the top executives of the
FBI one day he marched us down to the
nurses the quarters of the health room
on the 4th floor and he weighed us in I
weighed I was three pounds overweight
another person another executive was 12
pounds overweight one was 10 pounds
overweight so he constantly dubbed us
the dreadnoughts
and we were known that for a long time
but vanity was one of his faults and I
think he had a lot of vanity he called
him obsequious yes where did you that I
felt that he was somewhat obsequious in
his well let me put it this way
in the matter involving mrs. Claire said
all he gave me instructions not to
follow Lyndon Johnson's advice in
writing but he told Clyde told him to
tell me to go ahead and do it anyhow
to obey London Lyndon Johnson's
President Johnson's instructions insofar
as obtaining toll calls in Albuquerque
New Mexico where the president thought
Richard Nixon had stopped on his
campaign plane actually it was until in
Manila it wasn't Richard Nixon it was a
Spiro Agnew the vice president's for
Canada stopped to nag me I mean here I
had one in writing in telling me not to
do it and verbally telling me to do it I
felt that was somewhat obsequious say
let me go back though that was 68 the
campaign of 68th correct Lyndon Johnson
did not run in 68 Hubert Humphrey was
the candidate running against Richard
Nixon and Lyndon Johnson calls you or I
think you said Bromley Smith calls you
who was working for Lyndon Johnson and
says what
indicated that the president had
received information from the National
Security Agency indicating it missus
Chenal had been to the South Vietnam
embassy who is missus you know Ms Eclair
should all was a wife of the fine tiger
general Claire Chennault and she was a
strong Republican she socialized and she
was very close friends with John
Mitchell the Attorney General and was
Senator John tower and she also liked
and was friends with the Richard Nixon
but the desertion all had been to the
South Vietnamese embassy indicating it
it would be appreciated by certain
quarters if the Paris peace talks
if the South Vietnamese would not go to
the Paris peace talks that infuriated
President Johnson who was trying his
best at that particular time to get the
South Vietnamese and the North
Vietnamese together for the United
States at the parent T's peace talks to
close off the war in in Vietnam and he
was infuriated over the fact that
someone was trying to meddle in that and
in his opinion and trying to keep that
from happening the South Vietnamese from
being there so that's why he requested
the FBI through probably spent at a time
and later on he got into the act
personally himself but Bromley Smith
asking the FBI on behalf of the
president of Padilla surveillance on
mrs. Chenal and also to put a wiretap on
mr. Chenault as well as the South
Vietnamese embassy we did so at the
instructions of the president and
getting it in writing from Ramsey Clark
the Attorney General who was instructed
by the White House to give us approval
to do that now at what time in the
campaign was that October that nearly
years after Johnson had indicated that
he would not again seek the approval of
his party for the candidacy of president
he would not run again and he put his
strength behind Hubert Humphrey but he
wanted Humphrey to possibly get the
credit or closing off the Vietnamese war
and of course the Republicans wanted to
get credit for Richard Nixon for doing
it if the South Vietnamese
had not gone to the Paris peace talks
and Nixon had already become president
then he would get credit for possibly
closing off the war so consequently it
was a it was a fact of politics for a
desperate very definitely another aspect
is I want to ask you about though at
some point in the process FBI agents
moved into New Mexico and Albuquerque
and insisted to look at telephone
records and whether or not there'd been
a call place from Albuquerque back to
mrs. Chennault or the South Vietnamese
embassy from Richard Nixon's campaign
plane that's absolutely right but the
question I have for you is could FBI
agents even though this is a political
request insist and see any telephone
record in the country at any time they
wanted to if they had the cooperation of
the telephone company in doing so yes
and that particular time they were not
seeking to place a wiretap on Spiro
Agnew or Richard Nixon or anyone else
other than this at all which was done in
the instructions of the White House what
they were seeking were told calls and
his peril Agnew's fame in Albuquerque
roll shows top the phone was put on
board and five calls were made several
calls of late in New York one was made
to Dean Russ the Secretary of State at
that particular time there were no calls
made to visit Chenault
there were no calls made to the South
Vietnamese embassy but we did get the
calls who they were made to what time to
remain and we turned that over to Lyndon
Johnson now when he goes tell further
Brian one of the great allegations that
has been made which is totally false
was it the Goldwater group but that
particularly not the goal or group the
Nixon group at that particular time
indicated that and that we were
requested to put a microphone on Nixon's
campaign plane by Johnson this never
happened in the first place it'd be
almost a physical impossibility for the
plane being guarded at all times and
secondly even you did place it on board
it would be almost a physical
impossibility to to have it work
properly considering the unsophisticated
usage of equipment of that particular
time so that's a false allegation
otherwise we obtained the toll calls and
40m to the president now if I may go a
step further also he asked me to do this
at after seven o'clock one night and I
told him that be the wrong thing to do a
terrible thing to do it would lead to
allegations concerning the FBI being a
Gestapo waking people up and
particularly getting information from
the telephone company which we come no
later on and bring stigma to them so he
came back on the pone and he said who do
you think is your commander-in-chief and
I told him I said - no doubt in my mind
but what you are but I'm trying to save
you from embarrassment and also the FBI
for embarrassment and he said all right
but you better have in the morning and I
did have it the next morning COINTELPRO
what is that one tell parole is a
counterintelligence program it was used
widely against a queue closed plan it
was used widely against the Communist
Party it was successful but we made
mistakes in that program and we
particularly made mistakes by letting
one of our assistant directors who was
under my supervision and therefore I
must bear some responsibility also but
he operated many times without the
authority or the knowledge of the true
Burke lied tolls from the knee and as a
result we made mistakes in that regard
but I'm William Selim William Solon
William C Sullivan yes what year did he
die I believe it was 1973 or for 1974 I
believe he died in a hunting accident he
was shot by the son of his chief of
police who faulted he heard a deer
walking along a roadway in the forest
are there still people this day that
suspect that that wasn't the case I mean
that was a controversy at the time who
shot William some the facts are so clear
that I've heard nothing indicating it it
was a conspiracy but sometimes the
American public is very gullible and
just like the John F Kennedy case the
Martin Luther King assassination case he
there Bobby Kennedy case the
assassination there Lee Harvey Oswald
Jack Ruby thousands people have made a
living out of raising conspiracies
concerning those cases and yet the facts
down out in a stark
manner very factual the evidence is
overwhelming about who kill who and how
did it happen and so on but still you
have people among the American public
who will believe these wild and woolly
conspiracies but you always come back
full circle to the fact that Lee Harvey
Oswald in the Kennedy case James Earl
Ray in the cane case and Sirhan Bishara
Sirhan in the body Kennedy case and you
also come back somewhat full circle from
to thank it there's a common denominator
here each pan if you'll examine his
background wanted to go down into
posterity or committing the worst
atrocity he could find in order to well
to go down in history and to be
remembered by the American public
they were loners they wanted attention
and they got it this is mixing apples
and oranges but the Co Intel program
both a program and Martin Luther King
and dagger Hoover and communists now
that I'm lumping all that together
because you have a whole chapter about
King versus Hoover yes let me just ask
you a general question did was there are
communist influence in your opinion with
Martin Luther King I felt that the two
individuals whom I mentioned the book in
New York attorney by the name of Stanley
Levison who was a member of the National
Committee of the Communist Party a fella
by milord L was hired by Levinson Jack
Coonan Jack Odell and who worked with
the National the Southern Conference
leadership group had Levison's
instructions who had history of being a
member of the Communist Party that
raised the taint of possible association
with dr. King or at least influence on
dr. King now the big allegation today
here again is the fact that the we
harassed dr. King our Hoover harassed
dr. King by placing a wiretap on him
wiretap was ordered by attorney General
Robert F Kennedy
Burke Marshall who was head of the the
assistant attorney general in charge of
the Civil Rights Division at that
particular time stated to the wiretap
was placed because Bobby Kennedy didn't
know what else to do
dr. king
been warned by President Kennedy in the
Rose Garden about association with
Levinson and association with Odelle
Burke Marshall II talked to him Bobby
Kennedy to talk to him but dr. King knew
that while he knew the facts involve
there obviously felt that he needed
these men or disbelieve the allegations
concerning their communist connections
because he kept them on regardless
now dr. King himself was not I have
never seen anything that dr. king
himself was a member of the Communist
Party I feel that in my own opinion that
dr. King was somewhat naive politically
or else he needed these men to the
extent that he kept them on a news
conference that was held with Sarah
McClendon who is still active in this
town and Miriam Ottenberg
and about 18 women kicked off a public
dispute between Martin Luther King and J
Edgar Hoover and what was that all about
how'd that happen a blind you know
probably better than I do the influence
of women and the journalistic feel in
Washington DC at the present time the
National Press Club had refused to admit
women to his membership they considered
they brought considerable pressure on
the National Press Club to finally you
know women were admitted but they formed
at that particular time the National
Press Club group of women organization
and in Miriam on Berg of the evening
star Sarah McClendon and other notable
women reporters were on that and writers
were in that group they had tried every
way in the world again a meeting with J
Edgar Hoover and he had turned them down
until finally he couldn't turn him down
anymore he had to allow these women to
see him and to allow them to question
him but we've worked for several days
working up what he was going to say
facts figures fugitives RICO fugitive
called
auto automobiles recovered etc etc but
they were bored they didn't like those
statistics they could have gotten those
in writing from the annual report or any
other source
Hoover's testimony before Congress so
Hoover sensing that they were bored I
decided to give them some startling
information if we do that how often the
janitor who ever meet with reporters
this was the first time and also the
last times far as I know really ever yes
he met with individual female reporters
from time to time and individual male
reporters and individual male reporters
but not this is person only time that I
know of it he met with them and you
quote him saying at this point in the
news conference when he thought they
were bored quote it is my opinion dr.
Martin Luther King is the most notorious
liar in the country that's correct he
did say that I passed him a note I was
startled Bob wick who was with me at the
time inspector an assistant director
work with me at the time a man that
reported to me was one of the best
assistant directors we've had a very
good man but he rolled his eyes and he
looked at me and I looked a little
startled and I passed director Hoover a
note saying don't you want to keep this
off the record and he took the note and
he balled it up and and threw in the
trash I passed him another note later on
saying don't you think that remarks
concerning King should not leave this
room he threw that away the third time I
passed him a note toward the conclusion
of the press interview he looked at me
and he said no he told the women he said
the Loach's told me to keep the remark
concerning dr. King off-the-record he
said I refuse to do so you may print
them as I have given them to you well
the women left the room like a roof was
falling and they couldn't wait to get
the telephones and that started the feud
all over with dr. King it had quieted
down considerably but they had started
up again as a result of that and it was
a public relations Fiasco what was the
dispute over anyway that mr. Hoover he
say was mad about something that Martin
Luther King said you're right Brian when
the dr. King went to Albany Georgia he
was going to have a campaign there dying
so far as integration was concerned the
business of blacks references that are
etc but he expected violence and
violence of course gives out with a lot
of publicity causes a lot of publicity
but the chief of police that particular
time at Albany was chief Laurie
Pritchett and Pritchett was a very
experienced law enforcement officer he
was a I think a very civic-minded man
and he met dr. King with kindness with
the courage he did not use dogs or fire
hoses as the chief of police in
Birmingham Alabama did and to the
contrary Pritchard met him with every
kindness in the world
there was no publicity dr. King did not
get the funds to mount anything in
Albany and as a result he made the press
release indicating that I presumed to
get into to get publicity he made a
press release indicating at agents of
the FBI were seen in the company of
police officers and of the agents in
Albany Georgia on were born reared and
educated in the south and as a result
the afro-american or the black in Albany
Georgia can I get a fair shake in civil
rights investigations
well Hoover was infuriated and properly
so because he knew that whether an agent
was born in the north or the south they
still gave equal treatment in so far as
investigation of civil rights matters
are concerned but to finish city to
answer your question if I may
Hoover immediately ordered a survey of
agents in the south and particularly
Albany Georgia he found that four of the
five agents assigned to Albany the dr.
King had seen were born reared educated
and raised in the north and he also
ordered a survey of all civil rights
investigation over a 10-year period and
he found none that had been where the
agents had been derelict or whether the
or where Afro Americans had been
shortchanged in those investigations you
see people don't understand even today
that an FBI agent can go out and
investigate a particular matter
within the jurisdiction of the Bureau
but the results of that investigation
must be submitted to the Department of
Justice to determine whether or not
prosecution shall in soon shall happen
so as a result if the investment FBI
investigates and the matters referred to
the Department of the mint the
Department turns it down insofar as
possible indictments or prosecution is
concerned people blame the FBI - are
carrying through on it the FBI is an
investigative agency not a prosecuting
agency and it never shall be it should
be how much was Martin Luther King
followed and bugged and taped as a
result of Attorney General Kennedy's
ordering the wiretap and the wiretap but
on dr. King that was used I don't know
the full length of time that was used
the wiretap came about as a result of
approval given by previous attorneys
general and I don't know how long I was
on but it was a determination to be made
by the Department of Justice as to
whether or not we had sufficient
information to indicate communist
influence on dr. King you say that you
have put a bug in his hotel rooms and in
his sexual exploits were recorded and
takes for passed on how did I was a tape
of all that passed on to his wife that
was done by William C Sullivan a
assistant director who followed the
Sullivan in his office found proof of
that later on and found out to Sullivan
and without approval from me from Clyde
Tolson from Hoover and an employee on
his staff take the tape along with a
letter which was composed and sent it to
Coretta King mrs. King Hoover didn't
know about that Hoover had no knowledge
whatsoever of that I was on the tenth
Sullivan did that strictly on his own it
concerned the sexual escapades which
occurred here in the hotel in Washington
DC and Sullivan had no authority to do
that and no right to do and it shouldn't
have been done it was a sickening act on
his part you say that Bobby Kennedy
liked listening to these tapes Bobby
Kennedy didn't I didn't say that the
Bobby Kennedy liked listening to the
King tapes I said Bobby Kennedy enjoyed
listening both in Chicago and New York
too
wiretaps are my big apart and microphone
all members of the Mafia the Cosa Nostra
or the mob or what have you and he
didn't in instances but one time with
quite a number of agents around him and
in New York was seventeen agents around
him and the question was asked at that
particular time by one of Kennedy's men
isn't this illegal and he said yes all
matters all at give you particular
matters are illegal but he also
complained about the fact that we should
get new equipment rather than using the
equipment that produced a wiretap at
their microphone that he heard the
microphone tapes because he said that
they were a little they had static on
them and therefore we obviously needed
you equipment all the people you worked
around and the president she served and
attorneys general and all that who is
the most principled person you were I
liked Herbert Brownell considerably as
an attorney general during the
Eisenhower years yes
and Bill Rogers I thought was he was a
very good Attorney General to get along
with John Mitchell was a no-nonsense man
he was later involved in the Watergate
matter and what the prisoners result of
it but John Mitchell while he was in
office was very friendly he was as I say
a no-nonsense man he'd leaving up
holding a letter of the law and he was
very easy to cooperate with how would
you characterize your own attitude about
politicians in general I think there's a
certain tenor which is increasing today
in the United States that in order to be
in politics you also had to be
hypocritical to a great extent you have
to practice yourself what you feel the
the tenor of the times is among the
people are going to be giving you the
votes and therefore you act accordingly
whether you believe in or not I think we
need to get back more to real principles
and politicians to practice what they
really believe in rather than what
majority please and perhaps or what
people bleed and now what I personally
feel about it that's that's my opinion
would you tell stories about old-timers
that are terribly positive I mean about
Estes Kefauver Estes Kefauver was this
spirit that he was a very apprehensive
or the fact he was going to be killed
and a drinker and a womanizer
exactly that was our opinion and but he
wanted to be protected he ordered an
investigation to find out whether or not
of the bomb underneath this house in
Tennessee and and we refused to do it it
was an hour already to do things like
that not within our jurisdiction yes I
think they're very fine senators and
verifying congressmen in some respects
by others are hypocritical to a great
extent how did you get into this in the
first place in the FBI yeah where were
you at the time I was a student in law
school as Justin University in DeLand
Florida I heard that the $8 saboteurs
had been arrested by the FBI within the
seventh 72-hour period and I thought
rather than becoming a lawyer and
getting on in private practice or going
into the service that particular time
like most of my classmates were going
that I would go into the FBI and I
researched the matter research the
Oregon facts about the organization and
thought it was a good hard-hitting
striking organization and it proved to
be just that now after a year and a half
and there I had left the FBI let me be
very honest about it
Hoover indicated at all agents under 24
years of age they had no dependents
should have their one aide a bigger
partner there deferred status taken away
problem
I knew that mine was going to be taken
away so I joined the Navy I stayed in
there for not quite two years I came
back to the FBI after then I wondered
Brian I wanted to be I wanted to combat
duty and I applied for it accordingly
but I was they found out the Navy found
out that I had played college football
I've been an FBI agent I've been to law
school so I was transferred to Norman
Oklahoma and played football and talked
to athletics there
long time how were you able to bring up
this size of a family an FBI man summary
it was tough not easy
somebody had to my wife is a marvelous
cook she is a marvelous Handler and
handler of the family and she deserves
far more praise than I do in the rearing
the family and kids go on to be FBI
agent no they haven't but I have three
sons of the lawyers that ones with
Disney World in Orlando Florida and
others with the with Velasquez
incorporated as assistant general
counsel in Michigan and a third one is
head of the town's legal services in
Hilton Head Island South Carolina your
book is endorsed by Sam Devine former
congressman and FBI agent Jack Anderson
syndicated columnist and Paul Harvey
different personalities was that your
idea yes I've known them all very well
what was mr. Anderson's relationship
with mr. Hoover Jack Anderson I used to
have lunch together quite frequently and
he would drop about Drew Pearson and
occasionally I would grab a pie J Edgar
Hoover and the strict discipline it was
all on a friendship basis mr. Hoover did
not like Jack Anderson because well if I
may put it crudely he did mr. Hoover on
one occasion referred to Jack Anderson
after Anderson had printed a column
about Hoover accepting favors from
Richardson and Richardson in Texas and
mr. Hoover was very infuriated about it
and at women's
Press Club cocktail party which he went
to not an interview but it's strictly a
social matter the women asked him what
he about his opinion concerning aft
Jack Anderson and he said I think he's a
garbage picking and so and so Jack
didn't like that so he printed further
he had Hoover's garbage checked and
found out that he drank Jack Daniels the
low peppermint ice cream and saw nothing
derogatory but Jack Anderson always
played very square with me and reported
fact properly when he called me
concerning press matters and I enjoy
dealing with him
where was this picture taken in what
year well J Edgar Hoover I believe that
was taken in in nineteen sixty eight or
nine before I left in 1970
kartha D D close author of Hoover's FBI
the inside story by Hoover's trust in
lieutenant thanks for your time thank
you it's a privilege to be on your show
Brian